what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
doing a deep dive into the latest events
in the boku no hero story including the
ongoing battle between super shigaraki
and deku Bakugan and ever
Aizawa and all the other heroes in jakku
i will also be talking about the big
all-4-one twists in regards to shigaraki
a twist that could change everything we
thought we knew about both shigaraki and
his mysterious master finally i will be
discussing how this epic battle might
end and what kind of impact giganto
macchia and the other villains could
make if they can make it to jakku but
before they come to jakku they will have
to go through mount lady and the other
heroes back at the mansion as you can
tell there is so much to talk about so
let's get into it if you enjoyed the
pocono hero content on this channel and
you want us to keep it go and please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed yet please consider
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at anime up roller
finally this video will contain boku no
hero manga spoilers we are dealing with
the very latest chapters in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned just to recap really quickly
the previous installment of the story
ended with dec one bakugan defying grand
Terenas orders to stay out of the battle
instead of hiding out far from the
battlefield because she got Aki's main
goal appears to be stealing one for all
deco and baku go ended up attacking
shigaraki directly they chose to do this
because they saw that i suppose life was
in danger and they didn't want to just
sit on the sidelines while their teacher
and other heroes die at the hands of
shigaraki and a noble this latest
chapter picks up right where the
previous chapter left off with deco and
baku actively fighting shigaraki deco
and baku go explained that they couldn't
just sit back and watch Aizawa and the
other heroes
lose their lives on top of that since at
this moment
Shigure aki is unable to use his quirks
because of Aizawa this might be the best
chance they'll ever have to actually
defeat shigaraki back in the previous
chapter gran torino told Deku to stay
away from shigaraki because if she got
Aki somehow manages to get his hands on
one for all and steal it then that would
be the worst possible scenario for the
heroes but Declan baccala believed that
if they just stayed in hiding and she
kuraki managed to take out Aizawa that
would have been the worst case scenario
Aizawa would lose his life which would
be heartbreaking for them because he is
their teacher but more than that in that
case she got Aki would be back at full
power and able to use all of his quirks
if that were to happen shigaraki would
potentially become unstoppable so this
was the scenario that deck went back ago
wanted to avoid at all cost and so they
were willing to even put their own lives
on the line in order to avoid it at this
point
Declan Baku employs some pretty cool
team battle strategies Dec who uses
black whip to grab she got a key and
Baku go take advantage of the fact that
she rocky can't move freely to blast him
with his ap shot autocannon but as cool
as that looks in the manga it doesn't
seem to do any damage to shigaraki and
she got lucky even mocks Baku and calls
his attack little fireworks in the next
moment she got Aki's incredible physical
strength overpowers dec whose attempts
to restrain him and shigaraki gets right
in Bacchus face and tells him that he's
just not interested in him at the moment
you can imagine how Bakugan felt hearing
this after that whole exchange he had
with Deku about who is the real
protagonist in the story and just as she
got Aki is about to hit and potentially
kill Baku goal and ever arrives to save
the day once again the number one pro
hero smashes shigaraki with one of his
epic fiery punches and the impact of
this attack actually sends shigaraki
flying and everything asks deco and
Bakugan where Shoto
is but they reply that they're alone
Shoto is likely still helping the
evacuation efforts on the other end of
town
although it is quite possible that he
will show up here on the main
battlefield at some point in the near
future I can definitely see Shoto
appearing just in time for endeavours
eventual meet up with dobby and of
course burnin might also make an
appearance if that happens then we would
potentially get to see some really cool
teamwork from all the people from
endeavours pro hero agency and of course
with how strong she Gaddafi is right now
the heroes are gonna need all the backup
they can get so I'm sure once the
evacuation is over a lot of those heroes
and hero students might show up here now
even though endeavours punch was able to
send shigaraki flying it didn't do any
real damage to the villain shigaraki is
able to regain his balance and he is
actually glad that endeavour still has
some fight left in him gran torino an
endeavor then warned everyone once again
that the new shigaraki possesses
unimaginable strength and endeavour even
says that she got rocky strength and
endurance are now on the same level as
all might we know from what Hugo said
earlier that she Gaddafi is not quite as
strong as all might but he is definitely
up there and the fact that endeavour
just came out and said that this guy is
all might level is a big deal I think
it's fair to say at this point that she
Guara ki is the greatest threat that any
of these heroes have ever had to face
the strongest villain in boku no hero
someone who has near all might levels of
physical strength the awakened decay
quirk all for one and a bunch of other
stolen quirks at the same time is an
absolutely insane and certainly
unprecedented threat in the world of
boku no hero the heroes know that their
only advantage right now is the fact
that Eraserhead is cancelling out chigi
Rocky's quirks and so they must all work
together to stop shigaraki from reaching
Eraserhead
as long as Isola can continue canceling
out she got his quirks the heroes have a
chance but if she got rocky manages to
neutralize Aizawa and he goes back to
fighting in full power the heroes will
be in big freakin trouble because of the
unique nature of this situation and
never allows deco and baklava to stay in
the fight but he tells them that they
must protect Eraserhead
while
so ensuring that shigaraki doesn't kill
them as endeavor prepares for another
attack shigaraki experiences a strange
and potentially very important moment
something inside of shigaraki something
beyond his own consciousness seems to
take over at least for a moment and she
got if he calls out one for all give it
to me little brother in the very next
moment endeavour attacks shigaraki with
flash fire fist hell spider but
shigaraki again doesn't have too much
trouble avoiding the worst of this
attack
in fact she gareki is more interested in
understanding why he just called out to
his little brother when he doesn't even
have one shigaraki quickly realizes that
some part of all four ones consciousness
is still lingering inside his mind most
likely as part of all four ones quark
factor just like some aspect of the
former one for all users still lingers
inside of Deku so it was Oliver once
consciousness that called out to his
little brother not Shigeru keys and that
is a pretty big deal this seems to
indicate that after inheriting the
original all-4-one quark chigi Rocky's
mind is sharing two consciousnesses his
own and all for once all for one's
deepest desires are now affecting
shigaraki keys mind and this makes us
wonder whether all for one's
consciousness and personality are going
to keep affecting and changing shigaraki
could all for one potentially take over
she got Rocky's body essentially turning
him into a younger and more powerful
version of himself while erasing she got
Rocky's real consciousness and
personality what's this all for once
plan all along I mean you can't put
anything past someone like all for one
but after the way that he has treated
chigi rocky I have to say that trying to
take over his successors body and
erasing his consciousness would be cruel
even by all-4-one standards for his part
shigaraki is determined not to let
all-4-one take over shigaraki is
definitely grateful to all for one for
raising him and turning him into the man
that he has become but she got aki also
makes it clear that he doesn't want to
be like all for one he wants to be
better than all for one he wants to be
stronger
all-4-one and he wants to succeed we're
all for one failed all for one was of
course a notorious villain and he
definitely had his moment in the Sun but
at the end of the day all for one was
defeated by just one man all might on
two separate occasions shigaraki does
not want to follow in those footsteps he
wants to be an undefeatable villain a
villain that uneven all the pro heroes
together can stop let alone a single pro
hero shigaraki tells all for wants
consciousness to keep its desires to
itself because this is his will and he
will follow only his own desires
suddenly Gran Torino flies up to
shigaraki and slams into him Gran Torino
tells shigaraki to stop trampling on
Nana she morose heart with his actions
what a dimension of his grandmother's
name she got Aki acts like he doesn't
even know who Nana Shimura
is I wonder why she gerak he doesn't
remember Nana is it because his memories
were affected by the procedure or did he
just never know his grandmother's name
he definitely saw pictures of her in his
father's office back when he was a kid
so he should know who she was but maybe
her first name was hidden from him or
something like that or maybe he has
forgotten her as a result of all the
alterations that ichigo's procedure made
to his body and his mind at any rate she
Iraqis response just makes gran torino
even angrier and he tries to attack
shigaraki but shigaraki doesn't have any
interest in Gran Torino shigaraki wants
deku and he evades Gran Torino
effortlessly before once again turning
his attention back to Deku however as
she got Aki zeroes in on Deku Baca go
says the Deku was just bait before
unleashing a massive blast right on top
of shigaraki the heroes seem surprised
at the sheer power of baka was attack
and if this was any normal villain this
attack would probably have ended them
but this is no ordinary villain this is
awakened shigaraki and ever follows up
buff goes blasts with an epic attack of
his own an absolutely fierce flaming
punch and he appears to deal some
serious damage to shigaraki
but we don't get to see what happens
next or just how much damage endeavor
and baklava were able to cause she got
lucky because in the very next panel the
chapter shifts back to the villain
mansion back at the mansion
too literal Giants are going at it
the Giganta fied giganto macchia is
trying to push his way past mount lady
who actually looks considerably smaller
than he gonta machia at this point even
though she is in her giant form we can
see that Gionta macchia is carrying
multiple villains on his back including
toga Dobby and mr. compress he is trying
to push his way past the heroes in order
to join shigaraki on the jakku
battlefield but mount lady is doing her
very best to stop him and that is how
this insane chapter ends with two
massive hero vs. villain battles taking
place at the same time absolutely crazy
stuff is happening in this arc and we
just keep getting more incredible action
and more twists and turns with each new
chapter in terms of the mansion battle I
can't believe just how big gig on Tamaki
a-- has become he is practically the
size of a mountain just look at how
small toga and the others look while
riding on his back with that said
despite her celebrity status mount lady
has repeatedly proven herself to be a
brave and ferociously strong hero so we
shouldn't underestimate her
nonetheless seeing giganto machia at
this immense size and knowing that he
was just summoned by his master to jakku
i simply cannot see how mount lady wins
this fight giganto machia is an absolute
monster who is fanatically loyal to his
master so i think that he gan Tamaki out
will definitely find a way to overpower
mount lady he would do anything at this
point to do what his master wants and
from a story perspective in order for
this amazing arc to come to a proper
climax the other villains and especially
dobby have to make it to the main
battlefield in jakku so for that reason
I think Egan Tamaki out will find a way
past Mount Lady and the other heroes at
the mansion I just hope that Mount Lady
and the other heroes won't lose their
lives in the process in terms of the
shigaraki fight we
hope that Aizawa can hold out and that
our boy Manuel can keep moisturizing his
eyes because if Eraserhead falters even
for a moment
everyone is screwed even without his
quirk shigaraki has physical strength
comparable to all might and if he gets
the ability to use all those quirks once
again there's just no telling what he'll
be capable of doing especially now that
the hero forces are busy fighting the
normal not to mention how the situation
will change once gig onto macchia and
the other villains arrive nevertheless
this chapter did reveal one of Shiga
Rocky's potential weaknesses if she go
Rocky is currently facing a serious
internal conflict with the remnants of
all four ones consciousness inside his
quirk factor then perhaps shigaraki will
experience some internal mental turmoil
that the heroes are going to be able to
take advantage of so far it seems that
she got rocky is maintaining control but
perhaps that could change as the fight
continues what do you guys think well
she got Aki overcome all four one's
consciousness will his body be taken
over by all for one or could she got a
Keys personality incorporate aspects of
all from one's personality and evolve
into a completely different person as a
result some sort of combination of both
she got rocky and all for one also what
do you think is about to happen to Deku
Bakugan and ever
Aizawa and the other heroes are any of
them going to die during this fight let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more boku no hero videos
right here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to anime lore or you just haven't
subscribed make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
hitting that Bell and selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're gonna miss a lot of our
videos even if you're subscribed it's
just how you do works feel free to hit
me up on Twitter and Instagram at anime
uproar I want to give a big thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
making videos like this one possible a
very special thank you to f3
a a disciple of Lord Twigg Oh himself
and I can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world Steelers acquired respect
Pat a heffa Jonathan King deci D Brandon
Avila's Papa Smurf the school bus King
riser Emperor Taku Ritchie Martinez and
Thomas Jones and of course another big
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius Anatole Kazansky on hell
cruise cricket XP Joe Stanton very Gucci
alicia ahktar Jessica Calif on Tino come
in water Bonnie parks Zoda are twelve
rothwyn daiara Emperor cynical Kraken
full cast 77 and deadly Saint if you
enjoy our videos then you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]